[Music]
welcome back
so we're about to get into a really
really fascinating topic in vector
calculus where we start to think of what
kinds of vector fields
are irrotational what kinds of vector
fields are potential flows or
incompressible
so we've been using
div grad and curl
as building blocks for building up uh
partial differential equations
and we also can think about you know if
we have a vector field like the fluid
flow in the gulf of mexico
we can use the divergence and the curl
and the gradient to start to analyze
properties of those vector fields
and so
we know that if we have a scalar field
so given
a scalar field
any scalar field this could be like the
temperature distribution any scalar
field let's call it little f
of x y and z so we're in three
dimensions
then uh this establishes a vector field
by taking the gradient then
the gradient of f
is a vector field
okay and this is a pretty simple idea so
all we have to do is take
partial f partial x partial f partial y
and partial f partial z and that
establishes a vector field everywhere
in space
so for every scalar function we can
derive a vector field from that scalar
function just by computing the gradient
this could be the temperature
distribution
and a plate it could be the
concentration of pollen
in a forest it could be kind of any
scalar you want it establishes a vector
field which is the rate of change of
that in x in y and in z and so it really
begs an interesting question so the
question is
is a very natural question
is
are all vector fields the gradient of
some scalar potential are
all vector fields
are all vector fields big f
the gradient
of some scalar potential of some
[Music]
uh scalar
potential
some scalar field let's call it just
some scalar field little f
a very natural question it's an easy
question to pose and i want you to just
think about it for a minute we know that
for every scalar
i can derive a vector field
is it true that for every vector field
there is an associated scalar
that we take the gradient of to get f
now
right off the bat we should be thinking
no the answer the answer is probably no
and one really really simple way of
thinking about this
is that if you think of all of the
functions f of x y and z like it's a big
space of functions
but the space of vector fields f is even
bigger because this has three components
a function f one a function f two and a
function f three so in some sense it's
like there's three times more variables
needed to describe this
than
these scalar functions
and so for some random vector field that
i generate it probably is not the
gradient
of a simple scalar potential field
so it's only special
only
special
vector fields f
equal grad
little f okay only very special vector
fields are the gradient of some
potential
and uh one way we can
essentially start to understand which
vector fields have this property so
these are called potential flows
these are called
these special fields are called
potential flows
potential
flows or conservative fields so these
are essentially conservative vector
fields and you know if i take an
arbitrary function f and i compute its
curl so if
if f
equals the gradient of some little
function
then if i take
the curl
of my vector field we know that the curl
of a gradient of little f has to equal
zero then the curl of f
which is again the curl of the gradient
of little f
equals zero
so
we know that there's tons of vector
fields that do not have curl equal to
zero there's lots of f's that do not
have curl zero
and so the only vector fields that can
be
gradients of of a simple potential
have to have curl free
so all of these special vector fields
that are gradient flows
are also curl free so gradient flows and
i'm just going to keep changing colors
because i like it
so gradient
flows
uh you know grad f's
are
curl
free
or irrotational if you like they are
irrotational there's no rotational
component of these potential flows
and so any big f that has any curl at
all cannot be the gradient of a scalar
potential
so it's kind of a proof that not all
vector fields are the gradient of some
scalar potential field
and that's kind of an interesting
property
now we say that these gradient fields
these this is actually potential flows
are slightly more special than this
potential flows are irrotational
and incompressible so it's not just
irrotational they're also incompressible
so i'm going to amend this and say that
these are not called potential flows
these are called
gradient flows
good so my gradient flows
and potential flows are a subset of
gradient flows so i have a flow just any
vector field f establishes kind of a
flow along that vector field
and then um
a subset of that would be these gradient
flows
so grad flows
are f
that is the gradient
of some scalar like this
and then potential flows are an even
more special case pot flows
uh where it's not only irrotational so
this is irrotational
irrotational uh
with no curl
this one is irrotational
not irrational sometimes i feel
irrational irrotational
but it's also incompressible
incompressible
so not only is the curl of f
equal to zero but also we have that the
divergence
of f is equal to zero for these very
special pot flows
so it's kind of like a special case the
potential flows or a special case of
grad flows are a special case
of all flows
and so far i've only talked about
gradient flows we'll talk about
potential flows this is a whole lecture
deriving what is the property uh what
kind of flow fields have this property
very very important for aerodynamics
electrodynamics all kinds of interesting
flows live live in this potential flow
but let's go back to these gradient
fields so gradient flows
or gradient fields
notice that i'm using the word field and
flow completely interchangeably my
vector field establishes kind of a it's
like a fluid flow it's like a flow of
stuff in space
so my gradient field
or flow whatever you like
big f
equals grad little f
are conservative by construction so
these are conservative
conservative
because no energy is gained or lost
going around a closed circle
um so no energy
gained
or lost
when we
move a particle or a mass or a charge or
whatever
through
a closed orbit
or conservative no energy gained or lost
moving our mass
or our charge
around
a closed
loop
and so you can think of like a an
amusement park right okay so we have um
let's say we have you know earth earth
is pulling in uh it's got its
gravitational potential we've already
looked at this a little bit
so this uh is
the earth's gravitational field
is the gradient of its potential so your
potential energy is you know a function
of the radius from earth
and you can take that scalar function
and take its gradient and you actually
get
the force field of how earth is pulling
you on kind of in these directions
pointing towards the center of the earth
and so if i have you know a roller
coaster with no friction so i have some
roller coaster with no friction
then when it goes in a closed orbit no
energy was gained or lost
through this this cycle so if i have a
frictionless roller coaster then it
would just go on forever and ever and no
energy would be gained or lost in this
potential field
so that's a really really important
property of these potential fields is
that they are conservative vector fields
they conserve
energy okay
good um
and that's because like the energy
is this potential function f in our case
f is the potential energy so if i make a
closed orbit that goes to the same point
with the same energy it is conserving
energy energy is not gaining uh or
leaving the system in that case
okay cool so we've talked a little bit
about how now now what we're thinking
about is we have all of these vector
fields f okay so we have
uh
vector fields
f
and these vector fields have properties
they could be
[Music]
you know div
equals zero or they could be curl
equals zero if it's just curl zero it's
a gradient flow if it's div and curl
equals zero zero it's a potential flow
and it turns out
those conditions specify which partial
differential equations these f's are
solution to
so these vector functions f
are
solutions
to partial differential equations and
again those pdes encode physics like
conservation of mass momentum energy
conservation of angular momentum
uh conservative vector fields so pd our
pdes encode some physics
and the solution of those pdes are
vector fields f
that have certain properties like
sometimes they're div 0 for
incompressible fluid flows sometimes
they're curl 0 for conservative
potential flows
and so we're going to look a little bit
more but this is a really really
important idea is that
the solutions of our partial
differential equations are offered often
vector fields
and the properties of those vector
fields are often related to properties
of the original conservation law that
went into deriving the pde
okay good
so now we know that there are gradient
flows that are irrotational there are
potential flows that are both
irrotational and incompressible
but in the larger realm of of just
general flows that are neither
incompressible nor irrotational so for a
generic flow let's say
you know for a generic
flow
big f
we can always write this function
as the sum of two components one of
which is irrotational and the other one
of which is divergence free
so we can say that f is equal to minus
grad of some potential function
so this is a curl free vector field
plus
the curl of some other
vector field a
okay
so i'm going to walk you through this
this is in fact called this is a really
important
property of vector field all vector
fields can be decomposed this way
and this is called the helmholtz
decomposition helm
holtz
decomposition
and in higher dimensions it's also like
on manifolds on on on curvy manifolds in
higher dimensions
uh it's called the hodge
uh decomposition
just telling you what it's called in
case you need to
kind of ever look this up uh
decomposition
and i'm not going to tell you exactly
how to compute this potential and this a
for for any vector field f but i'm just
telling you that this definitely exists
for any generic flow f you can decompose
it into an irrotational component here
and a
a solenoidal component here so i'm going
to write this out this is
the potential
flow
part
this is conservative irrotational
so conservative
conservative
and irrotational
and this part is called the solenoidal
field this is the solenoidal
solenoid
part of the field
and this one is rotational
but it is incompressible this is
incompressible
and that of course relies on the fact
that the divergence of the curl of any
vector field is zero so this has to have
divergence zero
this has to have curl zero okay and so
any vector field can be broken up into a
irrotational part and an incompressible
part and this part is the conservative
part of the vector field the part that
conserves energy this is the solenoidal
part that just kind of rotates things
around but it's incompressible
and this is a really really useful
decomposition in a lot of physics this
comes up a lot in electromagnetism it
comes up a lot in the fluid flow
equations and navier-stokes equations
kind of all throughout physics
also when we do calculus on manifolds
this hodge decomposition comes up a lot
so really cool idea these vector fields
f which we often think of as the
solution of a partial differential
equation have properties sometimes
they're entirely irrotational or
entirely solenoidal remember
an incompressible fluid flow
has to have this incompressible like it
has to have this this divergence free
condition so they have to be solenoidal
vector fields that's really interesting
so if my partial differential equation
is the incompressible navy or stokes
equation then i have to get out
solenoidal vector fields f out of that
that's pretty cool okay and so there's
lots of things like that that you can
use to help you find these solutions and
derive these pdes and you know this is a
big big field
hundreds of years in the making we're
still figuring it out for non-linear
pdes so stay tuned for more in the next
lecture we're going to focus entirely
on this class of potential flows which
are really really important uh important
in physics these essentially give you
these are the solution of laplace's
equation and a lot of harmonic analysis
and complex variables uh is really
focused on finding the solutions of
laplace's equation which are these
potential flows so that's all coming up
soon uh thank you